Congress needs to come back into session
like tomorrow okay if all of our
scientific resources are needed to get
this vaccine tested done designed and
ready to go as soon as possible so we
can go back to being a free country if
that's the metric then we all need to
know that now
so last night I called on Congress to
come back come back to DC do your job be
part of the whole of government approach
yeah if that means allocating more money
to get a vaccine on the market faster
then so be it
President Trump says this is a war so
let's act like it now as I said earlier
Congress was in session almost
continuously throughout World War two
and during most of the disease pandemic
in recent history of course the 1918
Spanish flu where members of Congress
stayed on Capitol Hill to pass vital
public health legislation they put their
lives on the line literally that
outbreak actually killed a handful of
lawmakers
joining me now it's senator and dr. and
old friends senator john barrasso
of Wyoming and California Congressman
Devin Nunez senator Barrasso let's start
with you you're also a physician every
time someone has an ache and pain on
Capitol Hill they call you up so why not
have Congress come back to ask some of
these questions about the metrics that
we're using the studies that we're using
given what's at stake for our country if
this shutdown goes on much past April
30th the president called me this
morning and his number-one concern of
course is the health and safety of the
American people and we have just passed
the largest bill in the history of the
United States that the President signed
of the cares Act aimed at providing our
medical care givers everything that they
need taking care of our families our
small businesses and our hard-hit
sectors what we need to do is make sure
that is implemented properly the last
thing we need to do is to pass another
bill on top of that we need to make sure
and I'm visiting with hospital
administrators and doctors in Wyoming
and small business owners this is where
I need
to be making sure that this two trillion
dollar bill is implemented properly
congressman min is you heard that during
the pandemic of 1918 during World War
two Congress was in session almost
continuously
very few breaks I know everybody wants
to get home with their families but I
mean we we have Americans who are
freaking out either from getting this
disease a virus or from losing their job
and never getting it back and they're
they're not they're not sure what the
ultimate success rate will look like and
it's it's their legitimate questions
that people are having thoughts well
look I think it is important that we get
back as soon as possible but as Senator
Barrasso said right now we still have an
issue that most people and employers and
employees don't understand that
employers get two weeks of sick leave
still a lot of businesses still have not
implemented that that's the way to keep
two weeks of everybody still working
that's part of the money that we did in
phase one people don't understand that
in Phase two that we just passed last
week two and a half times the payroll
that businesses can go and borrow and
get that money ultimately turned into a
grant so I am dealing with with all of
these issues trying to get this message
out I think you know quite frankly all
of America's politicians and the media
need to stop looking at the death
counters and I think you're very right
we need to look at the death rate let's
see what that's going to do we need a
lot more data but let's stop looking at
the death counters and let's talk about
how we compete keep as many people
employed as possible that's the key
right now Laura because if you don't
what you said earlier is correct when
you have people staying at home not
taking care of themselves you will end
up with a hell of a lot more people
dying by other causes than you will by
the coronavirus senator Barrasso there
was a moment at yesterday's press
briefing that a lot of people who had
their eyebrows raised after after
watching it I want to play it for you
and get your reaction
watch roadmap also talks about
doing GPS for social distancing maybe
follow up following people's phones and
hotels for isolation for people giving
them free hotel rooms are those ideas
that you're looking at well the GPS
that's a very severe idea I've been
hearing about a GPS and what happens a
siren goes off if you get too close to
somebody that's pretty severe we're
taking a look I just I just received it
a little while ago he sent it over well
he's talking about the roadmap to
recovery that the former FDA
Commissioner wrote over at AEI he sits
on a bunch of farmer boards as well
which is fine but the part of that road
map included a possible GPS tracking
senator Barrasso of individuals under
the state lockdown orders do you support
in any way the administration ever going
up even close to that the president
certainly didn't seem to see to believe
that would be something we would require
well I agree with the president no I
don't think we ought to go that way look
this coronavirus has impacted the lives
and the livelihoods of so many it should
not impede on our liberties as American
citizens so I'd be opposed to what
they're doing with the recommendations
they're talking actually about doing
that in Europe that's been written about
as well I just can't imagine the
American people would be willing to do
that I think the most important thing we
could do and you've been really good at
pointing this out in terms of jumping
ahead of this is doing the kind of
research that's being done with all
these different medicines they're about
five different medicines that are being
tested not the old scientific
double-blind give them a sugar pill
approach see what is working in the
field even if it isn't a cure these are
medicines that are available and we know
are safe because people have been taking
them for years and even if they don't
give a full cure if they can lessen the
symptoms or get somebody back back
healthy sooner I think that is going to
be the breakthrough much sooner than a
vaccine which even the quickest vaccines
can take two or three years to develop
now this back to that Gottlieb's roadmap
that the White House they bow Chi and
they're tight and they really rely on
Gottlieb's advice he basically says we
can't go back to a normal life until we
have a vaccine
that's basically what he says that that
would be not going back to normal life
congressman Nunez for 12 months which it
parents across the country are hearing
that and workers there there they're
gonna be showing up in Washington even
if you all aren't here okay
they're gonna be coming to Washington to
send you all the message yeah that's not
gonna work I mean look the schools were
just cancelled out here in California
which is you know way overkill I mean
you know we it's possible kids could
have went back to school in two weeks to
four weeks but they just canceled the
rest of the schools so look I'm
optimistic here I think that the drugs
that are on the market now look how
quick we were able to get this approved
this new malaria drug that you've been
talking about every night there's a lot
of optimism here that would that we have
in in some of these drugs that are
coming online that vaccines are going to
take a while but look we have this bill
that we just passed last week 2.2
trillion dollars worth we have to focus
on keeping people employed I will tell
you this if we don't start to get people
back to work in this country over the
next week to two weeks I don't believe
we can wait until you know the end of
April I just think I just don't know of
any economy that's ever survived where
you unplug the entire economy and expect
things to go back and be normal so you
know the more tests that are out there
the more people that are getting testing
the let's learn about the treatments
let's get good data as to who's being
impacted yeah and let's figure out a way
to get back to work all right senator
and dr. Barrasso and Congressman Nunez
great to see you both stay safe out
there